[Music]
you love the Power Rangers when you were
a kid now take a trip down memory lane
and realize what was I thinking
this is terrible
fighting Morphin Power Rangers the movie
before they try to make a grounded
reboot out of rainbows suited teenagers
karate fighting a grumble B we visit the
first ranger project that didn't rely on
archived Japanese footage which only
makes it worse
now what's their excuse you know it's
that when the rapping pumpkin looks
better than your CGI robot
oh you'll Ranger make me bad push me up
with a rap that bad follow the exact
same formula that cranked out over 800
episodes of television where Rita
summons a monster the Power Rangers
fight their minions hand a hand someone
gets really big I feel my god and the
Rangers morph into a sword to save the
day
[Music]
but this time everyone's parents get
drugged into committing mass suicide
whoa Sega dork returned to the 90s and
era so extreme every group in the high
school to the fire department has their
own competitive skydiving team and get
popped they cause all your favorite
teenagers with attitude have returned -
the attitude he also none of the actors
were actually teenagers and three of
them are actually replacing your
favorites from the show my frog but
still three of your favorite non
teenagers without attitude and no active
contract disputes are here like Tommy
the only one you care about Kimberly the
damsel in distress and Billy the nerd
who was bullied so badly he walked off
the show I was worried that I might take
my own life dude again dark when Sydney
I'll strip the angel Grove is attacked
by either news a Freddy Krueger ish
slime monster welcome the Rangers will
travel to Sydney off another planet to
gain the power of the ninjetta
which I believe is italian for ninja and
all new way to make it easier to swap
the actors out with their stunt doubles
now they'll come together to save the
universe from evil with a fresh set of
action figures
I guess ninjas are cool job new
accessories and a new awful-looking Zord
complete with emergency junk kicking
action oh right in the bulkan skull so
gear up for this feature-length episode
of what's basically a live action
cartoon that was so forgettable the show
ignored it and did their own episode
about ninja powers instead you now
possess the power
John seek with a no coal but at least it
gave more fuel to every Power Rangers
fans most important question are Tommy
and Kimberly hooking up or what if
Bakken one
now the Jason's out of the picture they
have to be right it's so vague story MMA
actually kick your ass Pinky and the
brain the sorceress from the he-man
movie Fred Savage
Bela from Raiders of the Lost Ark
seriously needed a paycheck pointless
back handspring
[Music]
whooshes let's go get the other one and
the more you know teenage Morphin ninja
Yeager's smells like
teenager so clubs and Axe body spray oh
yeah hey screen junkies want more 90s
nostalgia then take a trip back down
memory lane to a tale as old as time for
our honest trailer of Disney's animated
Beauty and the Beast or if it's still
morphin time click the Box on the right
and watch our interview with the cast of
the new Power Rangers movie hiiiii it's
morphin time
how many lows could Rob Lowe Rob if Rob
Lowe can rob lowes this mil is rated s
were spoiled you're a turd this get
hairy pooter and a chamber of secret
parts
pneumonoultramicroscopicsilicovolcanoconiosis